foreign
[Music]
I think there is absolutely no limit how
bad this can be because confidence has
absolutely been shaken the stock is
plummeting like there is no tomorrow
creditors have reduced their limits to
this particular group from 50 to 70
percent ltvs or in in case of margins to
zero
foreign
[Music]
there have been forcedent activities in
times of inventories in times of of the
business activity or the business
development that the company has been
talking about so I think from investors
perspective the sentiment is immensely
adverse towards this particular stock
foreign
[Music]
and everything is secondary hence to
insulate the investors
from potential losses we have withdrawn
the fto
this decision
will not have any impact on our existing
operations
as well as our future plans
[Music]
feel like